someone else did this hair and this
makeup for a different shoot today and I
really put it up by adding this
beautifully fitted gray tarp to the mix
hello everyone
last week I made a video showing you how
you can make some Valentine's Day treats
and this week we are doing another
Valentine's Day themed video because
Valentine's Day is a lot like a great
relationship you don't see it coming and
then all of a sudden it's just
suffocating you this week we were
talking about Valentine's Day themed
gift because you can't just celebrate
love by loving you have to celebrate
love by giving tangible items so here
are three easy DIY Valentine's gift
ideas that I came up with all by myself
after looking at Pinterest for a long
time and wandering around the Michaels
there's a gift idea for friends a gift
idea for significant others and a gift
idea for complete strangers because no
one is left out on Valentine's Day
unless you definitely are watch this our
first Valentine's DIY is going to be for
a friend and what a better gift for a
friend on Valentine's Day then a
decorated tissue box or this you're
gonna need a tissue box that's kind of
like your friend sad and plain then
you're gonna need whatever kind of
crafting supplies you want to decorate
your box I got some markers some
mirrored mosaic tiles some colored
papers and stick on letters and a hot
glue gun then you're gonna take a second
and think if it's weird to get your
friend a Valentine's Day gift then
you're just gonna do it anyway the first
thing we're gonna do is take our tissue
boxes and be a total weird and unique
goofball thing it's sad because we're
just so generic we forgot to put
lipstick on thank oh my god it broke oh
jesus has a plan then I decided I was
gonna decorate my tissue box with these
mirrored mosaic pieces and you can lay
out some sort of pattern or design for
yourself but you'll quickly realize that
most of the things that you plan in your
life call to [ __ ] anyway because Jesus
is constantly testing you so what would
Jesus do stick it anywhere I just
randomly stuck these mirrored tiles
wherever I wanted on the box and it
surprisingly turned out pretty good I'm
capable but I decided to leave the last
side open so that I could use my stick
on letters to write a message that I
thought really represented my friend
and then I just hot glued the rest of my
mirrored tiles around my custom message
and wah wah a custom-made Valentine's
Day tissue box for your friend now when
your friend is crying to you about their
own personal struggles and heartbreak
you can tune out by looking at this
handcrafted tissue box you made them and
get lost in your own thoughts about how
great you are you're like your own Jesus
this next video idea is for the person
you're bumping you're all Glee's with
your significant other or this you're
gonna need a plain pillowcase in any
color you like and some printable
iron-on transfer papers to eventually
print on a photo of your projected
elderly self don't worry it'll all make
sense people listen to Jesus and he said
crazy [ __ ] all the time so the first
thing we're gonna do is download one of
those apps that turns a photo of you
into an old person photo of you I think
the app I downloaded it's called old
booth to take a photo of yourself and
turn it old and then print it out on
your iron on transfer paper and make
sure you read the directions on your
transfer printer package because I did
this so wrong at first which means I'm a
human being and not Jesus Christ the
next step is to plug in your iron which
you totally forgot to mention that you
need for this because you're a human and
you're not Jesus then you're gonna cut
out your terrifying because it's
slightly too real elderly image of
yourself then you're gonna position the
image on your pillowcase off-center
either to the right or the left then
you're gonna take another plain shirt to
use as a buffer between the image and
the direct heat of the iron I like to
call this a DIY condom always practice
safe crafts and sex
that's a Mary didn't she give birth to
Jesus Christ and because it's definitely
true it can only imagine what could
happen to my body once the image has
been successfully transferred onto the
pillowcase you'll notice that it is
different than in the last clip because
like I said if the step because I'm not
Jesus Christ and I had to redo it and
this was the proper way to do it you're
gonna refill the pillowcase with an
actual pillow and wah-wah you have a
romantic pillow for your loved one that
they can lay next to when you're not
home it's like they're laying next to
their future if they weren't afraid of
commitment before you can also make one
of these pillows for yourself if you
really want to scare yourself into
taking care of your skin this last DIY
is a Valentine's gift for a stranger all
you're gonna need are some lettered
beads and any sort of chain to make a
necklace it can be any kind of chain you
want the sky's the limit
Jesus made a lot of fish out of a little
bit of fish but I didn't know how to
make pants
the first thing you're gonna do is open
your lettered beads let's start to spell
some Valentine's Day Eve phrases and
words here are some of the ones I came
up with then you're gonna take your
beads and string them on your necklace
and wah wah
you have a beautiful Valentine's Day
necklace to give to a complete stranger
all you have to do is go up someone in
public and then this and walk away the
same way Jesus just came into the world
I'm just shopping and left because he's
definitely real but there you go there
my Valentine's Day themed gift ideas I
hope that this was a fun time for you I
hope that this inspired you I hope that
you make some of these gifts on your own
if you do send me photos or go donate to
my GoFundMe account for speaking you can
tweet me follow their times on Instagram
we'd be making these these gifts for
anyone in your lives and don't forget to
subscribe here on this channel if you
like these videos because I would love
for you to come back insert Jesus joke
here happy Valentine's Day I don't know
well